so we've just seen a property that chris
is managing and overseeing this one is a
rent to rent property that he's
controlling
very interesting story i'm excited we're
in liverpool center i'm excited to see
this one
it's actually a rent-to-service
accommodation that's when you rent a
property
but then you manage it yourself you list
it on airbnb on bucking.com
and you keep the profit you don't own
the property you control the property
and chris is the master at rent and rent
with the bcs accommodation the
last thing you need is control of the
keys and access for guests when they
come in so this is one thing we do
we do it across the htmls anyway just so
we can go to any property without having
to carry all the keys
we know when we get to any property we
can get access yeah so it's something we
implement across all of them but
for certain accommodation definitely
would recommend it
some not a small timer chris christie
yeah i'm listening about
so this is one of them this is an
example of one of the one of the rooms
at the moment so this
we have with with the covid that
happened
uh we were we had bookings all the way
through the year and it was
it was it was cash flowing amazingly how
much we making uh it's on the good
months we were grossing between eight
and ten so we're cash flowing
ten grand a month yeah and profit from
that was anywhere from two to three
between that a month very nice
yeah what's happening today so at the
moment we
because of all the extra steps we took
to get into place uh we managed to get
contractors in uh on a long on a
they're here they say they're here for
12 to 18 months
but so they're taking it month by month
because they don't know what's happening
but we managed to secure contractors to
come in
and take six rooms out of this so that's
six rooms with the contractors there was
a peak there was a period in the summer
time
where there was people just leaving lost
the jobs couldn't pay couldn't do this
so when you've got a portfolio of like
say
just over 90 rooms in total i
and you have a small percentage even 10
percent of that there's no nine there's
nine rooms in a rent-a-rent strategy
that's that's profit loss so this went
from really profitable
to absolutely terrible to
just about doing okay yeah we've gone
we've gone from up
to down so we're handing the keys back
to where okay
you always have properties that
underperform over perform and just ones
that perform and it sounds like this is
done all throughout
it's not what i wanted to so i prefer
just to have it nice and steady of
course you do
do that but uh it's the ups and downs of
property i guess isn't it
up into the room all right so this is
oh wow this is a little bit more yeah
it's uh
we had to open this up to say to try and
make it more homely get people in so
so this is what chris has done okay he's
found the landlord he found the landlord
on spare room
and was having a tough time yes because
he was managing himself tired landlord
chris said
i'll give you a guaranteed rent and i'll
take the whole block
and now chris rents these studio
apartments out
on booking.com airbnb
what's the most popular online travel
agent it's for this one the best
platform we find on bookings is
booking.com we try and
cater it more towards uh originally it
was
nightlife party goes weekends et cetera
because of the location with
with city center location football
traffic
football's gone nightlife's gone so we
had to really change everything about
this
so you've gone from tourists to
contractors yes
so you've just you mentioned uh who
who's in here at the moment who's
staying here now
there's six contractors and there's a
couple stadium here
uh for two months at the moment in this
in this particular it's all full
uh seven out of the eight rooms are full
well done by the way
great job but you know what they need
how i say i want to show you this one
this property as such because like i
said it was a
it was amazing it was glorious and then
it was down it handed the keys back no
that is that's true that is interesting
we pulled it back the lesson in this is
adapting is pivoting
so chris used to market to tourists
you were making crazy money buddy then
the pandemic came
bang wiped it tourism's gone but most
people then hand their keys back
oh this doesn't work anymore what you've
done is you've adapted it might not be
quite as profitable as it was
but you've now adapted and you've got
contractors in the place now
yeah that's what you need to do in
business you need to pivot you need to
adjust so how many how many like tenants
or or guests at one time could you have
a maximum capacity
uh maximum capacity we can have it's 96
is the knight is the money there's four
more make it 100 baby that's a target
yeah it's the flats above it
again another block of four four by nine
is this one making money this one's good
yeah oh that's good make it stand out
more than most of them
the guy who owns it he's uh quite to do
[Music]
so there's four flats in here two beds
two bed two beds and a large single bed
makes sense to have more
more than one in one yeah it was uh
then you've got one landlord one point
of contact but
multiple properties well these are fancy
very nice hey this is nice so we can
this is a
tenants living in there at the moment so
don't mind us coming in we've checked
and cleared but
this is classed as the single single
room because
it's how we laid it out but as you can
see there's such a large space
yeah wow that's big there
who's chris who's the market then who's
gonna who's gonna stay in this place
we targeted this uh at both initially
the the bulk of it's going to be
contractors yeah
it's contractors that monitor friday uh
the thought being with us so close to
anfield
uh we could then open up to weekend uh
commuters if they want to come watch the
game etc and we did
have before kobe we did have bookings in
here
uh for the the weekend's tourists here's
the thing
folks we've covered 19 around
tourism is dead so if you're going to do
service accommodation you can still make
money
but tourism is dead so if you're going
to do service accommodation you've got
to adapt
into contractors or and business people
so you've done really well even in the
bedroom we did put this sofa
uh we toyed with the idea with it being
quite close to anfield yeah again
thinking football traffic
the contractors we got in we put the
contractors on a monday to
monday to friday but we said they could
stay weekend if they want but if we
want the weekends to use for a service
accommodation we'll do that
yeah so before covert again we were
getting bookings in
so we're using this motorcycle with
contractors and then rents out the
weekend as i say
uh so in the bedrooms we've got four
beds in there
a double and two zipping links or simple
links with a case of two singles
and a pull out sofa bed so overall you
can sleep up to
six eight people in here so what how
much you paying the landlord for this
entire block
uh we we had a really good deal on this
one i don't mean
in in that sort of way it was just uh he
wanted quite in a
high amount yeah however i use the
negotiation of saying well i'll furnish
it
but i'll pay you less yeah so we ended
up paying 1500 for this
for the whole thing for the whole thing
wow but obviously i had to spend the
money to furnish it then to get it in so
yeah but overall it's how much profit
are you making each month on this
uh with the contractors alone it's
upwards of fifteen hundred
and then what about with the on top of
the system when the essays we say we're
about two thousand
two thousand so you're making a solid
solid fifty fifteen
pounds per month profit on this deal and
this is just one of 13.
one of the things yeah not bad here's
what's gonna happen now
i'm gonna sit down with chris we're
gonna have an interview i'm gonna pick
his brain
on exactly how he's done what he's done
that's coming tomorrow though okay so
the full interview is coming tomorrow so
if you want to see
the interview you have to subscribe to
the channel chris should they subscribe
to the channel i think you should
how did you first hear about me was it
youtube it came on youtube yes
uh ready books they'd load the books
before i get into property i just i was
i was a firm believer in getting into
everything getting all the knowledge
podcasts audio books
paperback books yeah uh youtube channels
everything and
that's when it came about really so you
started off watching youtube videos
however how much different do you think
it is when you can actually change your
environment and be around people that
are doing it
but they're just watching a screen
that's the key thing that i've found
that's the biggest thing for me because
as well spoke about before i kind of set
up a business before
i joined the academy so i was already
doing it to an extent
but the environment that you're involved
in with the academy for instance we have
what's that group some facebook groups
with some key members that we're
constantly in touch with
i'm doing deal i've set up a deal
sourcing company uh with another cabin
member at the moment
so we're always working there's jv
flying around between us all
the environment was what i was after
yeah
as opposed to just the solid show me the
people you hang around with and i'll
show you your future there you go
it's all about who you hang around with
so guys thanks for watching the video
please do me a massive favor though
subscribe turn the notification bell on
smash the like button if you want to see
my interview i did with chris
oh man like a year ago check that out
right here
there we go if you want to see the
interview i'm about to do with chris
right now you're gonna have to subscribe
to the channel and you can subscribe
right here subscribe watch the interview
i'll see you tomorrow